I believe physics has two goals first
it explains nature as you say we try to
decode some somehow the world that is
around us and to figure out what are the
laws that govern this world what what
happens in nature that's very important
but also physics creates new things and
now it's an avalanche now everywhere in
the world in every University there are
research groups research labs working on
quantum technologies and this quantum
technologies they they are spreading
still invisible and now one of the tasks
we are working on is to use these super
fluids of liquid light to induce super
conductivity at room temperature that
would have a huge economical impact and
it takes many hours sometimes more than
one day to grow a structure and that's
why this kind of artificial tree so that
they are much more expensive than any
natural crystals even diamonds then it
becomes dangerous because it means that
you can crack any code that nothing is
safe no one's vent account and also
pentagon with its nuclear arms is not
safe and people with good or bad will
can penetrate and maybe
trigger some some some unwanted
processes so here it becomes more
important and that's why quantum
computer is considered as a nuclear bomb
of the 21st century know someone's
opinion may contradict yours
why is my friend Allan it's all about
your perspective who are we in what is
the nature of this reality
[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Don Saki on we are on site
at the beautiful Westlake University in
Hangzhou China we are now gonna be
talking about light matter coupling we
have dr. Alexia Vulcan joining us on the
show hi Lexi hello thank you very much
for coming on really appreciate it
thanks man
inviting me it's a pleasure great
thosands hope you will enjoy it
Alexis background is so epic and I was
so excited for the content we're gonna
be sharing with you guys he's a director
of the International Center of polar at
onyx and chair professor at Westlake
University where his research is focused
on the physics of liquid light and you
can find all of his links in the bio
below okay
Alexey let's start things off with one
of our favorite questions we like asking
our guests what are your thoughts on the
direction of our world well what I know
professionally I have to know things so
I know that we are going through the
second quantum revolution now it is
called the first one happened at the
beginning of the 20th century and it
brought us Internet video cameras mobile
phones but also nuclear bomb and
everything that surrounds us and fills
our everyday life nowadays the secondary
the second part of revolution no one
noticed so far that it's happening but
it will have a very significant impact
on our life maybe in 5-10 years so this
is where we are going I don't know
exactly what is going to happen in terms
of our everyday life but more or less we
know that robots are coming and well
also things linked with security may
strongly change I think this is the most
sensible aspect because
cybercrime is something that no one
cares really about but it is going to be
a major problem I think much more
important than global warming in in just
a few years and the second revolution
brings new arms new new way upon and it
also brings new protection measures
mechanism well in this in this invisible
wharf info info crime and you know also
there is wind and we never know what
what's happening but between countries
between big players in this world there
is always some invisible fight in this
information space that so far is done
with use of classical weapons what we
call a classical computing but as soon
as quantum computers will come into play
it is like passage from conventional
vehicles to nuclear weapons it's more or
less the same kind of kind of transition
and it will be very serious
oh okay so I like this more big history
perspective on this massive advancement
of the first quantum revolution that
occurred and what incredible fruits we
got from that and how physics again is
pushing into new frontiers and getting
this towards the second quantum
revolution which I would love for you to
actually unpack a little bit more maybe
we do that a little bit later but just
and I love your focus on both the the
seriousness of this because it has
implications on both massive
advancements for society but also we
must be ethically morally
philosophically spiritually wise as as
that as that happens and it's very
important right so everyone
maybe knows that well can guess
that people were living happily even
before internet or cell phones and
actually at the end of 19th century the
world seemed to be perfect also from
from the point of view of physicists
they had a complete picture of all that
was self consistent and physics was
considered as a dead science no one
thought that physics will be needed and
that any significant development we will
be coming and then there were just
little signs that something was wrong
that induced some people to slightly
adjust laws of classical physics like
Marksville equations for classical
electrodynamics of Planck came with his
quantization of energy quantum appeared
and that was the beginning of 20th
century no one thought that this quantum
well may really come in everyone's life
but then slowly slowly with Einstein who
explained well there is this purely
classical relativistic theory of
Einstein but he also contributed to
quantum mechanics linking energy of
light to the frequency of light and
explaining that light is composed
actually by particles photons then then
there was bored with his model of atom
then there were other physicists and
slowly slowly it has become important
and when a president Harry Truman
discovered actually in 1945 that the
United States will soon have a nuclear
bomb it was a full surprise for him so
until then no one really was taken
seriously that but just a few months
later you know bombs were dropped into
Hiroshima and the new new epoch started
so now we are also living through this
this period magnet is invisible Richard
Feynman a great American physicist in
1950s he was the first to propose a new
way of computing that he called quantum
computation quantum computing
and it was just a theoretical concept
and then there were some mathematicians
contributions that some quantum
algorithms were proposed like shor
algorithm but it was just a game of
professionals in a very narrow research
field then at the end of 20th century
first attempts to realize what is called
qubits
the quantum bits that are needed for
quantum computation were so first
attempt published and now it's an
avalanche now everywhere in the world
in every University there are research
groups research labs working on quantum
technologies and this quantum
technologies they they are spreading
still invisible so what is what is new
what what what is that that exciting
about quantum technologies the idea of
quantum computing initially was very
nice that instead of doing operations
one by one you know with binary logic
the classical computer is it medical you
put in a classical computer a sequence
of zeros and ones and this is a binary
code and then there are operations that
transform these sequences of zeros and
ones to other sequences of zeros and
ones and at the end you take out also a
sequence of zeros and ones and this is
what equal cycle computer does the idea
of the concept of quantum computer is
that you also start with a binary code
but then out of these millions of zeros
and ones you make basically one state
that is some linear combination
something between 0 and 1 some some
mixture if you have or orange juice and
apple juice and you mix them you can
have any kind of mixture so classical
classical computing it only recognizes
purely orange juice and purely apple
juice but in quantum physics we work
with this all kind of mixtures and of
course the variety is normal and then
miraculously one when we take out the
information during the readout
again all these mixtures are transformed
into the sequences of zeros and ones
that we can convert into video into
sound etc etcetera so the computation is
accelerated by many many orders of
magnitude and and and and and so what
one can ask because of course even now
there are supercomputers that are more
powerful than classical computers but it
turns out that the simple quantum
computer with maybe 50 now Google
reported 53 qubits it may outperform the
most powerful supercomputer that would
work for four years so quantum computer
in in a few seconds would do the the
amount of rock that that the
supercomputer would do in in in years
now yeah and what okay there are fast
and slow computers of course our mobile
phones today they are much faster and
more efficient than huge computers in
1960s but now it comes to the problem of
security because everyone uses credit
cards everyone uses internet accounts
telecommunication telecommunication so
everything is protected somehow by
classical cryptography so usually
usually it is always the same trick you
type some password that is compared you
can digitalize it it's also in a number
any password is a number and this number
is usually a one of the elementary
factors of a wolf a huge number so we
have a huge number to factorize it and
any classical computer spends a very
long time on that and the quantum
computer using this char algorithm would
do it in in a second and then then it
becomes dangerous because it means that
you can crack any code that nothing is
safe no one's bent account and also
pentagon with its nuclear arms is not
safe and people with good or bad will
can penetrate and maybe
trigger some some unwanted processes so
here it becomes more important and
that's why quantum computer is
considered as a nuclear bomb of the 21st
century
Wow
oh my gosh okay let's go in with the
quantum computing considered the nuclear
bomb of the 21st century interesting
yeah because you are not supposed to
kill anyone with quantum computer but
you can penetrate any defense system and
you can then may be sent nuclear
missiles and destroy the world Wow
okay so I have so many questions let's
let's start with you are obviously well
versed in the history of physics do you
feel like physics is doing the unlocking
of the source code that was initially
launched with the Big Bang
I believe physics has two goals first
it explains nature as you say we try to
decode some somehow the world that is
around us and to figure out what are the
laws that ground this world what what
happened in nature that's very important
but also physics creates new things so I
initially I started my research as a
theoretical physicist and I quickly
realized that it is important that you
are able to explain some experimental
results but it is even more important if
you are able to predict something and
now now the quantum computer is this
pure product of human brain so this
great great founders of quantum theories
like Richard Feynman they invented it it
did not exist in nature there is no
quantum computers so it is it is a human
creature
physics is both understanding the laws
that govern our reality nature and it's
also the creation of this first quantum
mechanics Revolution which gave us the
computer which is can we also say that
this in a sense is a creation of nature
because it came through us which are is
the creation of nature oh
philosophically yes definitely yes a
creation of God through us but even the
quantum computer is then also a creation
of human creations are after all nature
creations and God's creations but still
as a physicist I know that there are two
completely different sorts of tasks one
you observe something and you try to
understand it and this is very important
but it is more conservative or the more
aggressive task you want to invent
something new test it try it and make
use of it okay so I like the distinction
so we have a process of observing
something and then and then Kaplan than
just running hypothesis for any
calculations understanding it better
over time
and then there's literally creating a
reality okay okay and so the the first
quantum revolution in the second are
more on the creating I would say it
started from interpretation of
observations results of observations so
atomic theory for example they were data
while of many experiments that provided
some information on the structure of
atoms so so people had to come up with
the model of atom so everyone knew that
the universe is composed by atoms from
ancient Greek time but no one knew what
is inside the atom and then different
models were tested Lord Kelvin board
cetera Arthur fort and
quantum mechanics was able to provide
the better model that explained all this
example of experimental data then this
same quantum mechanics was used to
propose like Einsteins it lazing for
example amplification of light by
stimulated emission of radiation this is
already a creative work of quantum
mechanics and of course nuclear bomb is
also something that did not exist well
it existed in sort because nuclear
synthesis and this kind of processes
that happen in stars but on our own or
else it was it was purely invented and
realized artificially how do you i love
the analogy with the orange juice and
apple juice so normal computing is
either apple juice or orange juice and
the quantum computing can be any
combination yes at every single yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah the the miracle is
then out of all these mixed States you
obtain a game orange and apple juice out
of an output yeah this is this is
projection of a quantum state so you see
initially you put in a classical state 1
0 1 0 0 0 1 etc this sequence of of
numbers then quantum computer starts
mixing them and you have some strange
mixture but then out of this strange
mixture again you extract here 0 0 1
code and this this last result is really
miracle of quantum mechanics because it
is called quantum measurement that
projects state to some classical basis
the famous example is a certain gift cat
and the quantum state is the cat that is
neither dead nor alive we do not know
the superposition state between dead and
alive but when we open the cage and we
check we find either dead cat or a live
cat and and this is this is what happens
also in quantum computers the
the readout converts a quantum state to
to some classical basis and in this
process of the the miracle happening in
the black box for so many of us that is
the quantum computing that the ability
to move from the normal binary into all
of the you all of the unique possible
mixtures and the computational and the
permutation or capacity of it to use
that process yeah yeah yeah exactly
there are two sorts of problems one is
purely mathematical because the binary
logic is well developed since several
centuries but this quantum logic it it
is not yet fully built there are some
algorithms that are tested that may be
efficient but not not as many as as in
classical logic so mathematicians they
keep working on it and they keep
inventing new new operations with these
mixtures what can you do with the mix
you can invert it for example instead of
65% of arranged and 35 of Apple you have
the opposite proportion this this sort
of things so new and new quantum gates
are proposed and and this this is a pure
theory then this needs to be implemented
so we physicists we we try to find
material systems and there are many of
them where quantum algorithms may be may
be realized and current currently I mean
there are over 10 probably different
systems including superconductivity
superconducting qubits called atoms
individual spins of whatever ions solid
state physics defects in diamonds for
example photons that is my field and
many more molecules that everything is
tested as a platform for realization of
quantum technologies quantum computation
it's not yet clear who will win which
material platform will be chose
the most efficient wow what a cool also
in a sense of race that's happening with
the second quantum revolution of which
style of quantum computing is going to
be most efficient or could different
forms be used for different applications
effectively that's I have another
question the question is about do you
feel like the amount of potential like
you warned us earlier that the potential
malevolence is that could be unleashed
with the quantum computational power do
you feel like it's our best way to hedge
against that problem is to work on
ourselves like morally spiritually
ethically philosophically so we can
learn how to use the technology on the
good side of it or do you feel like this
going really hard on the security side
of it is or do you feel it's a
combination of both how do you feel I
feel that so far the protection systems
it's not about human psychology
it's about physics again and the systems
are being developed this is what was
called quantum cryptography so instead
of classical codes that will be easily
cracked now many countries develop
systems that use so-called quantum key
distribution and China by the way is the
most advanced now in this area they have
the world first quantum satellite now
flying around the globe and this is what
is the quantum satellite quantum
satellite is a device where you generate
pairs of so-called entangled photons
photons that they that are like twins
they know each other they remember each
other even if they are very far so the
satellite sends two photons one goes for
example to be gene and another one goes
to Moscow or Washington
and this provides so these days photons
they encode they carry the code for for
communication so you send your encrypted
message through the classical channel by
internet email whatever but it is
encrypted using the code that you
receive from satellite and you if you
send the message you have the same code
as a guy whatever in Washington who
received the message because it comes
from the same satellite and it is
encoded with this tween tweent pairs of
photons and if someone intercepts one of
two photons the other one will be
immediately will feel it immediately so
you will just take it out and you will
you will be able to only choose safe
safe pairs of photons that no one
intercepted this is this this makes it
very secure this kind of communications
and entered exists already there is no
yet the worldwide quantum internet but I
hope it will be built maybe in five six
years who you said that young human
psychology doesn't really play that big
of a deal you we just have to build the
quantum encryption systems that are
going to protect like the quantum
satellite that's going to protect that's
going to entangle photons to protect
communication we have to we have to
build all of the security measures
because is it that we don't feel like we
can trust human psychology - right so
it's a question of funding human
psychology so decision-making mechanism
depends of course on human psychology
and politicians who give money to do so
that branch of research they're human
beings so far I think the approach
generally may approach of main players
like the US China Europe Russia it is
very conservative so money is given for
defense systems
and probably much more than for for this
dangerous systems but we don't know I
know one can can can tell you for sure
that there is no any private research
group who would really dig into
realizing this dangerous applications of
quantum technologies Alex do you also
consider it to be possible and what
would you say would be the proper
trajectory if so with human psychology
developing deeper morality and ethics
and philosophy and spirituality to the
extent at which we make it super
disincentivized period to ever behave in
a malevolent way to try and intercept
the communications or behave poorly with
the quantum technologies that way we can
maybe not need to go so insanely hard on
the security side of it well
realistically I don't think that the
whole population of this planet will
become so so good and that I always have
someone who who is tempted to do
something bad to to others and I think
this is in human nature and is difficult
to eradicate it entirely so I think this
is the reality that will that end we may
have to take it into account so we
should build our protective measures
it's not I don't believe that any
government nowadays is really willing to
destroy the world this I don't believe
but there are certainly dangerous
individuals who may have this oh that
goal that is potentially dangerous for
everyone
and also both happening at the same time
it's great a conscious evolution for
Humanity away from malevolence while we
also do some of the security advance the
security measures of quantum
cryptography Alexei um I want to know
more about your journey it's really
interesting hearing about your father
also being a physicist also your son one
of your children your son yes there's a
physicist as well seems to be like a
lineage of physicists will you tell us
about you growing up and how you got
interested in physics all right I was
born in the Soviet Union and effectively
my father was a professor and he did
some experimental research in
hydroacoustics so it was something
familiar to me from from a childhood my
elder brother who is seven seven seven
years older than me he has chosen
physics so it was quite natural for me
to follow their steps on that event I
always wanted to do other things
literature drawings music chess so
physics is not the only thing in the
world but it is interesting it is
challenging fortunately in the Soviet
Union there were very good schools so I
was fortunate to be graduate graduated
from one of this school specialized in
physics and mathematics and many
actually well two Fields Medal recent
fields medal winners this is the highest
distinction in math from the same school
Perelman and Smirnoff so it's a really
good education so then the Soviet Union
collapsed and with all this education we
had nothing to do because economically
it was a disaster you know the the
researchers at in the Academy of Science
they were paid on a level of maybe $20
per month so so everyone
either either you have to be wealthy and
but not so many people and so between
other wealthy or you we've had to look
for another job that is a pity we had to
go abroad and I went abroad like many
thousands of Russian scientists so I
worked in France I worked in Italy I
worked in UK and then now you know the
growth of physics is very international
it is not that important where I work
because always when contact with people
all over the globe and that's very
exciting this is one family and we do
not have any for example political
tensions in the world of research
absolutely nothing so yeah this is how I
come to China China is is really
exciting now it invests so much in
fundamental science it offers a really
fantastic environment and this is a
country of great civilization
yeah also they've had the difficult
times in 20th century but they managed
to educate many good students abroad and
now the students are coming back already
has grown up researchers and they take
leading positions in the universities in
China so the level really of Science in
China is growing very rapidly in
contrast with what we see in Europe
whatever Russia and even in the u.s.
it's it's not growing and that's that
that's speed I would say so yeah China
now is one of the most exciting places
in the world to do research agreed yeah
so this is a very part of the story of
the the rise and collapse of some of the
that's been happening over civilizations
since we started and so there was a
collapse and you went and you continued
doing your research you were you had
this drive towards the fundamental
science of physics and so you went and
you continued doing work in Europe and
you actually spent this is important to
mention you you spent 13 years from 2005
2018 right before you're moved to
Hangzhou at Westlake as a chair of
nanoscience and photonics and professor
of physics and astronomy at the
University of Southampton yes so during
that process before this moved to China
what were some of the big exciting
things that you were doing and teaching
and working on well in 2007 the group of
researchers of the University of
Southampton published the first paper on
now it will be a technical term
bose-einstein condensation of polarities
at room temperature but I explained what
it is so it is a game something with n
Stein Einstein predicted that there are
two sorts of particles in the world
fermions and bosons Thurman's do not
like each other they never stay in the
same state but bosons do like each other
and at very low temperatures bosons come
to the same quantum state that is a
state with the same energy same speed
same momentum so quick pause this is
this is at like CERN where you're we're
colliding particles this is well I
insert they they definitely study
elementary particles but to obtain these
condensates you probably need a
different experimental environment it is
not you don't need accelerators because
you need to cool them down to very low
temperatures in accelerators they are
very very hot but in I mean at the end
of 20th century in Cornell University
and in MIT people managed to observe
condensates of atoms atoms may be bosons
as well but at temperatures of tens of
nano kelvins so it is one billions part
or 10 b11 over 100 million of a Kelvin
or and 1 Kelvin now we are sitting at a
temperature of 600 Kelvin because the
temperatures
there's the temperature scale and okay
it was a great discovery they got Nobel
Prizes but completely useless because no
one would work at the temperatures only
in the borders you can achieve so low
temperatures so then in 2007 we have
shown that the same phenomena this
different kind of objects can be
realized at room temperature and I think
it is very very exciting when you bring
the physics that was known to be very
very exotic that only existed in a very
specific laboratory conditions when we
bring it to everyday life due to ambient
temperature
this opens huge fantastic field of
applications and from 2007 till now in
this 12 years probably several hundred
researchers came into this field and
again in all major universities in the
US and European in Asia people studied
this this phenomenon and this is all
about liquid light so Polara tonics my
center here is centre of pollutant so
polariton is this this particle that we
managed to condense so to put many
thousands of them into one single
quantum state when where this huge
amount of particles behave like one so
imagine you have cars on the motorway
and a traffic jam because all cars move
with different speed and some of them
are very slow and then others come and
then Jem is forming now imagine if all
of them move with the same speed exactly
the same 10,000 cars of a million cars
never Terrigen this is super fluidity
this is what is called super fluidity
and this is what we observe at room
temperature with this polarity it's
incredible so I think this was my iiiiii
was not the only one working on that but
I was a theorist of the group and this
is one of my most interesting research
works I would say and all subsequent
works were actually the development of
this one super fluidity of which
particle Polara turns whole era times
yes okay and polariton are come on top
of liquid light so light you know like
we will see light right it's something
that comes from Sun but a light is can
be can be described as a flow of
particles that are photons the quanta of
light so the Sun all the time is shining
photons in in all directions even these
lights are shining forth on yes yes can
you do you see the world that way do you
see yeah this is a quantum mechanical
picture of world light light is a is
composed by billions of billions of
billions quanta is that are these
photons okay and light of different
color for example red photons are
different from blue photons this is
about the property of photo slightly
different wavelength yes yes wavelength
frequency momentum these are
characteristics of photons but okay
these these particles these photons they
do not interact with each other they
basically they all propagate with the
same speed and they are described by
laws of optics now what we study is what
happens with light when it enters into
semiconductor crystals artificial
crystals made of semiconductor materials
like gallium arsenide for example so
light entering inside does not disappear
but it changes its properties strongly
so it propagates inside the crystal but
it also interacts when propagating with
crystal excitations
exit tones and this is how polarities
are born
that's how player tones are born so when
the light enters a yeah a crystal
crystal star crystal structure then it
gets coupled so you can see it like
light a photon is absorbed it disappears
for us for a short moment and some
something changes in the crystal so some
electron gains energy and goes up in
energy for example then this electron
comes back and the energy is released
again in the form of a photon and again
it is reabsorbed but from the point of
view of quantum mechanics there is no
separate photons and separate exit tones
excited states of elation but there is
some mixture against reason get cat that
is neither dead nor alive now so it is
not matter it is not light but some
mixture some liquid light we could like
make sure light matter coupling exactly
and this was a discovery by you and a
bunch of others oh well that's as any
discovery as many fathers so polariton
theoretically they were predicted in
1950s 1960s and then they were studied
in different materials and structures
but our contribution was that we have
shown that at some conditions these
polarities they all come to a single
quantum state that is this bose-einstein
condensate and this is very interesting
because a single control state water
please it is like single single particle
single object this is what I told you
about the cars they all move
simultaneously they all behave like all
like you see you know insects if you
have a lot of insects flying and then
yeah then they copy movements of each
other so the same happens with these
photos
she started observing liquid light that
was turning into a super fluidity
superfluid to fly a superfluid of light
and then what then
did when you when you when you guys were
there's you know seeing this happening
what were you immediately thinking about
regarding why this is so important what
it can be used for oh we had several
several ideas of potential applications
one of the first was about super
conductivity as you know it's it's one
of major challenges of physics since the
discovery of superconductivity in 1911
everyone dreams of finding material
where the superconductivity would exist
at room temperature superconductivity it
means that you pass electric current and
there is no losses and this potentially
can save you tens of billions dollars
and also there are some fantastic
applications like interstellar you know
flights and these engines that would
would much more efficient at anything
one can imagine now so this this is not
yet resolved and this is one of the
major challenges of physics but if the
superfluidity of liquid light exists at
room temperature I think it really shows
that also superconductivity may exist at
room temperature because two phenomena
are very very similar and now one of the
tasks we are working on is to use these
super fluids of liquid light to induce
superconductivity at room temperature
that would have a huge economical impact
one more times you say in the last part
again this would have a huge economic
impact the super conductivity if if it
is realized at room temperature at
temperature like like here now but then
we would it would be a new industrial
revolution
so the so the so the superfluidity of
light matter coupling makes super
conductivity yes I tell you the
difference between two a superfluid is
electrically neutral and the
superconductor is is a superfluid of
charged particles so it can carry
electric charge
that's why current that current that
propagates without any viscosity so
without any resistance and that that's
something that is used in accelerators
for example huge magnets but here in
China you have a train going from
Shanghai Airport to to the city this
maglev it is based on superconductivity
so it is it levitates it does not touch
trails but all this is achieved at low
temperatures and if you would be able to
to do the same at room temperature it
would have enormous economic impact and
now let's talk about this move so much
of this physics is incredibly complex to
to me and to so many others and it's
great hearing you aiming to make it so
relatable but it's just so complicated
at the same time with ah oh man look at
Liz it's no no no it's not really
complicated I think cooking for example
is more complicated than physics if you
want to become a good chef really you
need to to be much more talented and
then you would need to be covered at the
government good physicist I don't know
but because there are more factors you
know intuition plays in kitchen I like
cooking myself I know how little we can
rely on own recipes on written rules you
should have feeling physics is more
straightforward there are
and just apply them oh my gosh who would
have thought yeah well okay let's talk
about so let's let's see let's see on
this let's see what we can do here so
the so the discovery of polar tonics was
to around 2007 and and you have the this
is the physics of liquid light light
becoming liquid because it couples to
matter and then that process is critical
for superconductivity could unleash a
massive paradigm this and these are
things that are now happening with you
and your lab yes like this is one of the
goals not the only one and let's talk
now on this transition so okay you
mentioned earlier that you found the
amount of fundamental science being done
in China to be really important I do to
tell us more about that and about what
is happening here with your you
directing the International Center of
polar Atomics as well as being a chair
professor here at the University why
you're here I started a little bit more
than one year ago but everything here
the Westlake University is very new
because the university did not exist
until last year and this is very
exciting because rarely you have an
opportunity to build a center on your
own design from scratch from nothing so
I was given funds to build we are now
building several labs and I'm hiring
people there are two more professors in
our Center and some research scientists
and students are coming so hopefully in
one year will be about 3035 so already
big lab and
for my research field for this physics
of liquid light it is a unique
opportunity to bring together the growth
technology you know we need to grow our
artificial crystals where we fabricate
this liquid light it's not natural
crystals in it really needs reactor so
whatever to to make them how do you grow
the artificial crystals item by item
this is called molecular beam epitaxy
basically halves resources in a vacuum
chamber that send different atoms like
aluminum gallium and arsenic um
and they send them basically one by one
you you you grow the structural a
monoatomic layer by monoatomic layer you
can control it up to the position of
every single atom and this is an
expensive machine and but this is
something that exists in many countries
you're the machine's name one more time
molecular beam epitaxy molecular beam
epitaxy molecular beam epitaxy you can
take different atoms and then and then
have them create now you put them
nothing they form a crystal lattice so
they form a crystal lattice but how does
you can you see you can take the atoms
and have them one by one form this
crystal lattice and it's like it's like
3d printing in it's yeah it's kind of 3d
printing yes you can print different
kind of shapes three-dimensional shape
pyramids for example and you just feed
it whatever atoms you want it to print
no it's it's not that simple because for
every sort of atoms you need its own
source and then usually in a typical
chamber you have just three or four
sources so you cannot grow any material
you want you need when you buy this
machine you need to choose already the
the material materials yes okay so me
the machine is made do you know which
company mixta Oh many many
company's gonna be okay and then they
tailor the manufacturing of the machine
based on which Adams you want to yeah
friends yes 3d print to create so you're
creating artificial crystals what is the
size of these crystals what is the
internal like lattice structure because
how do you maximize the success of the
light matter coupling alright so the
crystal is grown on a substrate that
made of a couple of inch diameter and
there you you start covering it by this
very thin monotonic layers of the
structure that you're interested in and
it takes many hours sometimes more than
one day to grow a structure and that's
why this kind of artificial crystals
that they are much more expensive than
any natural crystals even diamonds so
then you have a structure that is very
thin anyway it is thinner than human
hair but you know precisely how it is
organized which layer goes after which
layer and and this is where you you can
observe some interesting physics a
couple inch plate has a mono atomic
layered crystal that is less than the
size of a hair which is about 50 microns
yes so so actually the substrate itself
it is not a theme it may be I don't know
0.1 millimeter if you low okay so okay
but then on the top of which you grow a
structure it is typically several micron
thick just just maybe three four month
and what is that structure at it on it
well structures we are using are called
micro cavities these are kind of you
know if an elevator sometimes they put
mirrors and you see your reflection from
both mirrors so
it goes between two mirrors back and
forth this is the same principle but on
a micro meter scale which is what makes
it so the photon goes between the two
between two mirrors and it the light
matter coupling just continues happily
happy yes
yeah the photo doesn't go out they think
is that it remains inside and then it
carved off more efficiently with some
crystal excitations and the crystal
excitations come from the container that
it's in fact that it's in this Kris
artificial crystal that you made yeah
it's it's well in any crystal a crystal
is made by atoms and in atoms you have
electrons in crystal what happens as
many atoms are close to each other so
electrons can jump from one to another
so they they forms kind of see so an
excitation is when you take one electron
from this C and you put it on a on an up
energy level so what remains in this C
it's arranged this empty place where you
took it with it is called
a hole hole it is a scientific term and
and and it can be described also as a
quasi particle with a positive charge so
this hole and this electron they they
attract each other they interact so it
tends to come back but during some time
it it lives above this level above and
then it falls down so this process it it
can be repeated many many times with
emission or absorption of the photon and
this is how how it all works this is how
the polariton appears now is the is it
well let's give a little bit more
technical here is the is the photon
coupling with the electron when it
connects with the with the lat with the
crystal lattice yeah everything happens
in a crystal a crystal is like a forest
you have this trees that and you you
walk
below the trees then you have squirrel
your electrons a school that jumps from
one branch to another and then I don't
know what analogy you can use something
have a ball and you shoot it to the
squirrel and the squirrel jumps up but
this will it's the same ball to you and
jumps down and and etc so this is and
and then then it jumps from one tree to
another and propagates two squirrels the
photon yeah the squirrel can be also the
electronic excitation because the
electrons in crystal they are free to
move okay now it's it was interesting
here and you say that us manufacturing
artificial crystals because there's none
of them that are naturally evolved that
we know of our more expensive than
diamonds yes and so every time you spend
a day printing one of these it's
extremely expensive yes okay and then
uhm there could you could we hypothesize
that there are other crystals that we
could make that could also assist us
with really hard
physics challenges oh yes this is this
is what this is how the this science
develops so people have ideas about new
design of new crystals wean our ethical
unit for example we always propose
designs then these designs go to the
gross laboratory they look at them and
they say no it's rubbish it cannot work
and we then we come up with a new design
and finally they take one and say ok
we'll try to do something about that and
then they grow a structure and and then
our optical lab is performing all kind
of measurements and then we see it is
not what we expected and then we go back
to the NSA no you have grown some
rubbish structure it's not what we
wanted and say they say oh yes we forgot
this is that this is this is how the
science goes forward and what do you
guys
get from the study of the light matter
coupling how do you take that and go to
superconductivity
how do you take that and go to photonic
quantum computing how do you that
translate to that yeah all right this is
exactly about designing different sorts
of starches so for superconductivity
what I need I need to take a
superconductor that already exists and
that has so-called critical temperature
critical superconductivity is achieved
below some temperature and above is
temperature it's a normal metal that is
not interesting so the critical
temperature for superconductivity is
very low and this is this is a problem
our challenge is to make it higher so we
cover our photonic structure our micro
cavity with this layer of superconductor
and we try to optimize the design of the
sample in such a way that the stupid
fluid of liquid light helps
superconductivity in this structure and
the critical temperature goes up if we
manage to see it where the happy winners
but it's not yet done for quantum
computing gets a different design we
need to make this cube it's you know the
mixture of orange and apple juice we
need to do it with our liquid light so
we basically we mix a light that
imitates orange juice with light that
imitates apple juice and we need to be
able to operate with that and control
this liquid
this requires well different sort of
structures that we engineer we produce
what do you hypothesize is the crystal
design that your team needs to make
superconductivity and photonic quantum
computing well we usually start from
intuition and this is what makes us
closer to this but then of course with
the only intuition you cannot go to the
gross and and run this tab that costs
many millions of dollars so after this
first intuition we do simulations we do
computer
modeling and we usually do not grow
immediately the complex structure that
would be the final one but we try to do
it step-by-step element by element we do
test and only when we are completely
sure that all together it will work we
assemble it and we go for the final
experiment
it's like launching something into other
outer space you would not just build it
at lunch you really need to be sure that
all your equipment works it should so
many of the leaders that we now
interview on the show use simulations in
some way shape or form and it's
fascinating now thinking about how many
industries that it's entering into
people are using it in order to be more
efficient yeah and and do you feel like
you can leverage the computational
capacity of running all of the
permutations of crystal structures to
see what could be optimal you know this
is interconnected because quantum
computers they are very promising also
for simulations for creation of new
materials this is the peaceful function
they are not only dangerous we're poor
but they they are they can be useful for
something and especially for super
conductivity because super conductivity
needs very complex structures and
classical computers even supercomputers
fail to predict their properties so we
so far we do not rely on that much on a
computer power we are doing it is not an
industrial research we are doing the
pioneering research and some
proof-of-concept experiments and for
this basically a small workstation can
fulfill our needs but I imagine that
when it passes on to companies like
Google IBM then they will switch on all
the super computing power to optimize
instruction because when you start mass
production you really put billions on
stake and you want
the best of the best and then what are
so would you say priority number one is
designing the crystal that's already won
yes yes well that may be
first you should have an idea you should
should realize you should formulate what
you want to achieve but once you
formulated it and you have a concept
then you come up to the design of the
structure and then priority two is
helping to move that process along of
the light matter coupling towards
superconductivity and photonic quantum
computing alright so once you have
structures you need also to perform
experiments that would be proof of
concept experiments it's it's also a
complex task and you know you would not
have immediately a quantum computer for
example you start with a single qubit
and then - then you assemble together
three or five it said okay I have a
question how does the light matter
coupling become the first qubit you see
one of the designs we are working on is
a so-called split ring resonator it is
like a Halfmoon cross son growing so
Crescent so here what happens we have
currents in this the superfluid currents
and discussions that go this way that
oscillate so if we say that current
going clockwise is our state one current
going anti-clockwise is our state zero
it's our basis and we achieve
superposition of these currents so it's
not all going only clockwise or only
anti-clockwise but it goes
simultaneously in both directions and
this is a qubit and then how does it
take all of the states between the
mixture of orange and apple juice ah
then it depends how you prepare it we do
it now with optical control so with
lasers we set up the face of this
oscillating currents as we need and then
then we also need to provide the readout
that is much much more much tricker we
do it with some interferometry
techniques on the nano scale so this is
this is challenging and not yet entirely
done and this is the central goals of
the lab one of what's our next no I mean
I mentioned to alright the
superconductivity and quantum
applications I can I can mention the
third one it is physics of monotonic
chains of carbon this is something where
we are really world leaders in
monoatomic chains of carbon is that
graphene no graphene laser is a
two-dimensional crystal in graphene you
have a Plane full of mono yes chain one
by one one but why why would you use
just the chain instead of the 2d oh it
has many many advantages it is the
thinnest vipe and imagined what a
finished wire that we can imagine
example so so so then for any kind of
quantum applications it is a quantum
where the electrons pass one by one so
electric current is quantized it is not
like it does not change greatly but it
changes step by step like that so this
is a very interesting object but it's
very challenging because it's not easy
tool to to make it to grow it the this
is inflexible you mean so the wire you
can potentially band it
yeah a single a single mono mono atomic
I can bend this you can it is the most
rigid wire because the distance between
carbon atoms is just 1 point 2 angstrom
so it's very very small they stick to
each other very well so it's very rigid
but you can still bend it hold it okay
and the you have to
do you have to are you using the same
machine except with carbon or a similar
style of machine with different this
these gross was his lasers in a liquid
in a colloid and first we basically with
the compose some target crystal into
fragments and then we extract this virus
and then we stabilize them attaching
gold nanoparticles at the ends and then
we deposit it because to use it you need
to put it on a substrate that's some
technology that that is actually also a
revolutionary technology we are now
preparing several papers on that we hope
that we will be the first in the world
to demonstrate this and apparently it's
easier to make lasagna
you know virus is really challenging and
not much is known about that this is
purely experimental in theory here is
not of much help because you cannot
foresee everything okay and then so
these are the three yes okay these are
the three for the lab now how do you
take the the the team right now is 10
you will be seeing it grow over time to
around 3035 how do you how do you end
the 10 and the amount of limited amount
of time that you have and all of the
complexity that you have to achieve with
doing the simulation modeling first of
the designs of the crystals and then to
conduct the actual light matter coupling
and then to see if you can go to the
stages of super conductivity photonic
quantum computing and then also doing
this other task with the mono atomic
carbon that's a lot of stuff for 10
people how do you figure out who's doing
what in this process well first of all
we collaborate with many labs across the
world and we Southampton by the way I
keep very good ties and with labs in
Switzerland in
deli in Russia and we have theories
coming from New York so it's it's it's
an international network basically that
that that tries to solve this problem so
we are not alone this ten people is just
maybe a nuclear but there are many
others who are involved okay we can't
forget about the children's books so
Alexei has authored ten children's books
now and this is the newest that right
yes our Cronus Chronicles and the
children's books inspire children into
history science yes yes you know I have
four children and initially I was
writing for them but then it turned out
that it is of more or less general
interest this particular book I was
challenged by a friend of mine to write
a book on Formula One races then I wish
my friend that so he told me that it
should be understandable so people
should understand why it is so
interesting and what is the science
behind these races because the result of
science involved here and it should also
promote his company that is called a
cronies so that's why the main character
of this book is an 11 year old girl who
is called Acronis and her brother is a
famous pilot of f1 and there is some
muffin wall so there is there is a lot
of adventures in this story and it is I
hope with the space was very funny and
easy to read but also it contains a
glossary where terms like pit stop pit
lane
whatever are explained and there are
drawings that illustrate everything and
you learned from this book what kind of
toys for example this cars need and how
often you need to change them during the
race things like that so that was the
first one first challenge and then she
changed me for the second book that is
closer to what I was talking about today
that's a Croatian quantum computer and
that
we'll be published hopefully before the
end of this year
Wow Cronus quantum computing Wow
and I love your your true
multidisciplinary man to be able to take
and make such complex subjects starting
with you know formula one and then
getting all the way up to quantum
computing this will be very interesting
to see how you synthesize and
disseminate at the level of the child
that would be very interesting
Alexei what is the meaning of life of
this big human experiment you know I've
had the professor when I was a student
in Russia and he was from Armenia like
you so he has any Armenian professor he
was very good in making speeches at the
table when we had parties so I remember
his his toast about the sense of life
he told us students in physics that you
know everyone wants to be happy in this
world but it's not interesting for for a
scientist for scientist the sense of
life is success so if you have chosen
this this field of activity you are
supposed to be successful this is this
is your goal be successful in your
research so I think it is very true in
my case and for my colleagues really
sometimes we forget our families we
forget to eat we forget to sleep because
we want a result and the success in in
science is very important for us and
that also speaks to the importance of
identifying what your gift or what your
unique gem is that you can bring the
world and just go after that with an
insane amount of appetite and hunger and
go do you think this is a simulation no
I think it's written
why well since you know science is a
real game it is it is it is a game but
it is about real things it's all like
like our life it's also sort of games
but but it is real and it makes it
interesting and last question what do
you think is the most beautiful thing in
the world
mm-hmm that's a very good question I
think nature is more beautiful than
anything artificial
so probably nature and then everyone
chooses well I like mountains for
example very much Alexey thank you so
much for coming on to our show and
teaching us this has been thanks a lot
so the players are so interesting thank
you thanks for all your great work best
of luck with the lab I think you look
thank you everyone for tuning in we
greatly appreciate it we'd love to hear
your thoughts in the comments below on
the episode let us know what you're
thinking have more conversations with
your friends families co-workers people
online about light matter coupling about
cutting edge physics about quantum
computation super conductivity about all
the things that we talked about the
grounding the second quantum revolution
and about how we can best maximize
prosperity moving forward check out the
links in the bio below again we have the
Westlake profile page for alexey as well
as the Wikipedia link and also the book
links check out the book share them with
your families friends and people's
online support the artists the
entrepreneurs the people in your
communities that you believe and support
them help them grow support simulation
we need so we can do content so we can
continue doing cool things like coming
on site to Westlake and interviewing
great people like Alexey go and build
the future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world we love you very much
thank you for tuning in and we will see
you soon peace that's a wrap Alexey
thank you so much honking are you gonna
run
may we that's for you that's all you're
so so kind thank you I really appreciate
this thank you I love this I'm so
excited you're I can't believe you're
doing one
[Music]
you
[Music]